well nothing says Christmas like drunk
driving and having the corpse of your
recently deceased sister pay you a visit
we're over halfway through season 4 of
True Detective and I'm still just as
lost with what's going on but fear not
we're going to try to narrow down what
exactly is going on in NIS with this
in-depth breakdown what spurred Julia to
walk out naked in the snow what does
Otis know about Raymond and most
importantly is Elf the only thing
playing on TV you sit on a throne of
Lies we'll dive into all this and more
but first take a moment to like And
subscribe and leave a comment with your
thoughts and theories below let's get
into it it's 3:29 a.m. on Christmas Eve
and Liz can't sleep just a few hours ago
she was shown this haunting video of
Annie koto's murder at least that's what
it appears to be remember that her body
was found in a shipping container not in
this underground Ice Cavern so the
ongoing theory is that she was killed in
the cavern and her body dumped in the
container we also know that her body was
stabbed 32 times with a sharp
unidentified object that created
star-shaped wounds shout out to the
binget toown TV podcast to observe that
these star-shaped wounds could be from
ice cleats if you want to know which two
characters have been seeing wearing
cleats like this definitely check out my
has the killer been revealed video which
I just released speaking of stars both
the silver sky and salal logos are
pretty similar with their six-pointed
star-like designs is this just a
coincidence or are the show's designers
trying to tell us something it's also
quite odd that any cell phone was found
in Raymond Clark's abandoned trailer
Raymond is currently npd's lead suspect
for the murders of the salal scientists
the fact her phone was found in
Raymond's trailer means that it had to
have been transported from that ice cave
but if Raymond killed Annie why keep
this phone which has incriminating
evidence of her attack and why leave
that phone right out in the open Liz
pauses on this image in the c talk video
These dark markings are most likely from
fossilized whalebones we can get a
better look at them in the intro credits
Liz and Navaro will go on to meet with
Adam Bryce the town's High School
geologist Liz visited in episode 2 Liz
makes Navaro answer the door considering
Adam's wife knows Liz slept with him
years ago so it's a little awkward is
there anyone this time you fued there's
really only one area around Enis that
has these whalebone Ice Caves Brooks
range but the area is extremely
dangerous and has been closed for years
due to accidents one wrong step in the
whole bottom to drop out from under your
feet I can pretty much guarantee someone
will be falling through that ice in the
upcoming episodes the only person who
can help Liz in Navaro navigate this
treacherous landscape just so happens to
be the only match Peter picked up of a
man who had sustained similar injuries
to that of the salal scientists this is
Otis height and on April 20th 1998 he
sustained burnt corneas ruptured eard
drums and self-inflicted wounds but
there's no record of how he got them
like Oliver tagak who we met briefly
last episode there are almost no records
of Otis no address or documentation so
finding him will be a problem it's time
to say goodbye to the corpsicle I
will you the team from Anchorage is here
to pick up the bodies and I'm very
curious what their autopsy report will
say and to oversee this is lizza's boss
Connelly things in Enis haven't
necessarily been Sun shine and rainbows
we got six dead bodies increasing
protests surrounding the mine and their
main suspect is on the loose so he's
wanting to make sure everything is okay
especially if he's going to be running
for mayor in the upcoming election
Connelly wants Liz not to tell anyone
that the scientists died before they
froze which I thought was a bit
suspicious you keep that on a need to no
basis so Connelly good guy or is he
hiding something I like this quick scene
of Liz going into Lee's room to check in
on her while she's sleeping it shows
that she really does care about her even
though there's been friction between the
two as of late but what I found really
disturbing were these faint screams
after Liz shuts the
door why have that in there are those
screams from something that happened in
the past and is it somehow related to
the deaths of Jake and Holden Liz
doesn't like bringing them up likely
because the memories are too painful in
fact it's the death of Jake and Holden
that prompted Connelly to transfer her
to Anis in the wake of their deaths Liz
just became a shittier person I thought
you hated Nar I do I hate everyone well
Liz may have been a good detective her
rapport with others was terrible and no
one wanted to work with her so far Liz
has experienced two flashbacks with Jake
and Holden one where Liz dances with
Jake and the other where Liz and Holden
listen to Twist and Shout on the radio
this is why she feverishly tries to turn
off the song at the salal station the
memories of the song invoke the pain of
losing her son and thank you to those
that found out in the closed captioning
that the song William wheeler whistles
in episode 3 is you guessed it Twist and
Shout although how you get Twist and
Shout from this is beyond me this
episode also sees the death of Julia
Navarro's little sister we first see her
in the middle of the street taking off
her clothes foreshadowing what she'll
later do this prompts Navaro to sign her
into a mental health facility something
she promised she wouldn't do both Julie
I and Navaro know this is the only
option with her mental health
increasingly on the decline later in the
episode we'll see Julia travel out into
the tundra and place her clothes in a
neat pile before venturing off into the
darkness it seems like she's
experiencing the same thing the
scientists at salal did whose clothes
were also seen folded in neat piles but
why would Julia do this you could argue
it's her mental health but if that were
the case why would the salal scientists
fold their clothes and go out into the
tunder as well as far as we know they
didn't suffer from schizophrenia or
bipolar disorder like Julia did perhaps
it's the family curse that Navaro
believes targeted their mom Julia and
now her one in which a voice calls out
to
them this leads into a very compelling
argument I found from user for Rusty
brain on Reddit which theorizes that
Navaro is this season's killer this
theory is so interesting and insane I
dedicated an entire video to it which
I'll leave a link to in the description
below if you're interested the third
Theory involves the mine in what's
called Mad Hatter disease a form of
chronic mercury poisoning the protesters
have long suspected the mine of
contaminating the town's water which
would likely contain high levels of
mercury exposure to this can lead to Mad
Hatter disease which has symptoms of
delirium hallucinations and even
Suicidal Tendencies Julia has a
hallucination of an orange rolling under
her bed we saw Navaro have a similar
hallucination last Epis episode but
Julius is accompanied with the corpse of
her mother with this cross necklace in
episode 2 Navaro found this exact
necklace in her car but back to this
Mercury high levels of it would also
explain the uptick in still bursts as
mercury is more easily exposed to a
developing fetus because it is a
neurological disorder who knows what
effects it could have on someone already
suffering from mental health issues so
it's very possible that Julia's mental
health combined with prolonged Mercury
exposure put her in a state of delirum
and that had her roaming naked in the
tundra the Mercury would also explain
the hallucinations by other members of
the Town such as the oneeyed polar bear
which could be real or imaginary it's no
coincidence that the show has made a
concerted effort to show us various
characters using water like Annie's
brother Hank brushing his teeth Navaro
brushing her teeth and even Liz maybe
just some water don't you just hate it
when a show makes you feel for the bad
guy that's exactly what happened to me
when Hank was stood up at the airport
where he was to meet his future Russian
bride Alina a few episodes ago we
learned that Alina was using Hank for
money stating that her mother was sick
this is a major red flag Hank doesn't
even answer Peter when he asks whether
or not he sent money to her and Hank's
in a state of denial saying there must
be some reason she didn't come perhaps
something bad happened to her mother but
what do you think is he getting Tinder
swindled or is his Russian bride the
real deal I've also heard this hilarious
theory that it's actually Liz catfishing
Hank because multiple times throughout
the season Liz has asked what she's
doing on her phone and she says
something like oh it's Tinder or oh it's
fantasy football I don't think she's
catfishing but it would be hilarious if
true Navaro visits Rose who's all
dressed up for New Year's Eve we learned
that before she came to Enis she was
some sort of serious writing Professor
but can we really believe her remember
that in episode 2 her story about
falling in love with rust Cole's father
Travis doesn't line up with what the
detectiv said about him in season 1 as
we can tell his props never had leukemia
no hospital records of that fact nobody
in that town Alaska seen Travis Co in
more than 30 years I also don't think
Rose is Russ biological mother as in
season 1 we learned that this mother
basically ran away from the family
prompting Travis and Russ to move to
Alaska the show also suggests that agono
isn't Rose's real ass name why hide this
unless it's something important Liz gets
called to the mind to find that her
daughter graffitied the words murderers
across the front last episode we saw
Leia an anti-mine rally and this seems
to be one of the main causes of
contention between her and Liz and if
things couldn't get any worse Kate
mckitrick who works for the mine and I
don't believe the show is confirmed if
she's actually the owner well she
threatens to press charges this isn't to
punish Lee but to punish Liz for
sleeping with her husband years ago and
I found it kind of funny that the
higher-ups at this mind Drive
eco-friendly Teslas Lee is visibly upset
at Liz and doesn't want to spend
Christmas Eve with her Liz has even
prepared a turkey which was set up last
episode but the one line that really
stuck out to me was this I'm not going
to make you pretend anymore what did Lee
mean by that pretend that everything is
all right that she is her daughter there
is clearly a lot more going on here than
their fight over the mine and if I were
to Hazard a guess it has something to do
with what happened to Jake and Holden
Navaro arrives home to find a present
laid out for her it's SpongeBob
toothpaste which more than likely means
this is from cavic as in episode one we
saw her using his SpongeBob toothbrush
Rush drunken alone just like how I spend
my Christmas Eve Liz notices that both
Annie's video and the one of Raymond
Clark have the power cutout right at the
last second and who would have
generators to power an ice cave or know
how to turn off the electricity at salal
that would be Oliver toak who was once
the equipment engineer at the research
station so she makes Navaro and Peter go
out to question him even though the two
of them should be spending the time with
family Oliver has fled the nomad camp
and it must have been in a damn hurry
since he left his shotgun gun and Boots
this would suggest he's come under the
influence of whatever power compelled
the scientists and Julia to disrobe and
go out into the tundra but Oliver also
left behind this spiral we can connect
the spiral to Annie who saw it in a
dream then to Raymond who dated Annie
then to the salal station where Raymond
worked and thus to Oliver who worked
with Raymond this image even links back
to season 1 but if you want to know more
about that check out my episode 2 video
none of the other Hunters know what this
spiral rock is or at least aren't
willing to tell them but Navaro takes it
with her perhaps someone in town will
know a bit more Peter has missed
Christmas Eve and Kayla is especially
pissed at him but as my dad often says
arguments are never about what they're
about what Kayla is really mad about is
that I ruined your life and you didn't
want to have the baby what a great way
to kick off Christmas and Christmas gets
even worse for Navaro who is told that
her sister's body was found by the Coast
Guard she takes out her rage on that
wife be beer from episode 1 getting
herself beat up in the process I wonder
if this will come with any repercussions
because if this happened in my town that
officer would be immediately fired Liz
is also found to be drunk driving by her
boss Connelly no word if that will come
back to haunt her but less likely since
the two are sleeping together she nearly
runs into that oneeyed polar bear this
polar bear is interesting because it
could be real or a hallucination
remember that Liz is drunk here and has
also been exposed to that mercury water
I tend to believe this isn't real
because what are the chances both Liz
and Navaro saw the same polar bear Liz
has a oneeyed polar bear plushy and that
same plushy was seen in a dream where
Liz's dead son tells Navaro to quote
tell my mommy Navaro gets patched up by
COC who resets her broken arm or fingers
there's this brief discussion about
being alone loneliness being one of the
major themes of this season Liz has a
dream of her and Holden but what I found
quite interesting was this intercut of
the town to cemetery implying that this
is where Holden is buried notice the
whalebones here something you'll find in
places like Point Hope Alaska when aaro
comes to check in on a hungover Liz
there's this big speech about how the
dead are dead and there's nothing out
there except us this is contrary to what
Rose said about hearing the voices of
the Dead if Liz really thinks the dead
are gone as Navaro points out then why
does she keep all these reminders of the
Dead like her son's polar bear plushy
when Navaro tells Liz about her sister's
death she says it's part of her family
curse both her mother and sister heard
voices and she's starting to hear them
now too Navaro kind of goes into a
trance here and Liz observes that Navaro
is doing the same thing she did with
wheeler a reference to her seeing the
ghost of the woman wheeler killed novaro
denies this I saw nothing we still don't
know what really happened to Wheeler
last episode Liz told Peter that when
they arrived at the crime scene wheeler
had shot his girlfriend and himself but
that's not what we see in the flashback
the implication here is that either Liz
or Navaro shot wheeler and they both
covered it up a call comes in that a
group of fisherman spotted a man
matching Raymond Clark's description
notably the pink coat that once belonged
to Annie this is out by the dredges
these large machines used for mining but
long since abandoned this place like
Raymond's van is covered in creepy
graffiti like this large spider and yet
another Spiral if a spiral was found in
Raymond's trailer and one here was
Raymond who did it but Liz and Navaro
aren't alone hiding among the pipes is
Otis Heist he is most likely a junkie
which M explain his cryptic dialogue he
tells Liz that Raymond has gone back
down to hide in the night country which
is also the title of this season night
country refers to the Endless Night
Alaska experiences in the winter months
but it looks like it could have a more
mysterious double meaning Navaro
meanwhile has gone off on her own after
hearing someone call her voice she's
hallucinating big time after seeing her
sister's dead body a body that can't
possibly be there because it was being
shipped back into town just like
Travis's body couldn't have been seen by
Rose because he died years ago and if
things couldn't get any weirder Liz
finds Navaro sitting in a trans-like
state by this batterypowered Christmas
tree I mean why would a tree be out here
in the middle of nowhere let alone all
festooned with lights that have to be
powered it's all very weird but more
concerning is Navarro's bloody ear Sim
IL to the ruptured eard drums
experienced by the salal scientists in
the corpsicle neither we nor Liz heard
anything that would make one's ears
bleed so either this is something only
Navaro could hear or a self-inflicted
wound but if you're like me and
wondering what the hell is going on join
me for the last part of this video the
trailer sleuthing section where we go
over the season's trailers to see what
we can expect in the episodes ahead I
want to start on this image of Liz being
interviewed a scenario we've been
familiar with in past seasons of the
show but what we don't don't know is if
this is a flashback of a previous case
or something that happens after the
events we're witnessing now in Enis
check out this shot from the initial
teaser where there's no dredge in the
background as seen in this episode I
personally believe that they just hadn't
completed the CGI or color grading for
this shot yet as this trailer came out
over 9 months ago but I'm sure there
will be some conspiracy theorists out
there will take this to mean that Liz
and Navaro are making up this whole
dredge event in their heads here's Liz
back at the salal station notice that
she isn't in her uniform even weirder is
that this jacket is a salal scientist
jacket so why is she wearing one of
these we also have another shot of her
back at salao but this time in a white
jacket so it seems we're spending a lot
more time back at salow out in the
tundra Liz falls through this crack in
the ice this could be one of two things
she may have fallen in one of those
fissures Adam talked about that leads
into the Ice Caves one wrong step in the
whole bottom to drop out from under your
feet or it could be this shot of her
falling into this wall water there's
also this shot of someone falling into
the ice cave so it's anyone's guess a
brief shot of Liz and Naro by the fire
looking exhausted as if they've just
been through some terrible ordeal Navaro
here also not in uniform with a bloody
nose judging from the background it also
looks like she's in Annie's Ice Cavern
this shot has me questioning whether
Navaro got kicked off the force and how
much time has passed as it looks like
her bruises from her fist fight have
healed Navaro also ends up at salal not
in uniform she meets up with Liz and it
really makes me wonder if both of them
got kicked off the force and are now
investigating on their own this is
really weird we have a shot of Julia as
a waitress having a mental breakdown
with her being dead either this shot got
cut or this is a flashback we have Lee
at a protest at the mine also see Navaro
here in riot gear I think this is Peter
dragging a dead body we'll get this
water shot where we can see him using an
axe to hack away at the ice here we have
a man possibly Raymond Clark going down
this ice tunnel remember that Otis said
Raymond had quote gone back down to hide
is it possible this underground area is
connected to salal hence why there are
so many shots of Liz and Navaro here
some sort of bloody Accident Happens
here at Liz's home but we can't really
identify who this person is that's
holding a bin of cleaning supplies
possibly Raymond here dragging who I
believe to be Navaro she'll eventually
get the upper hand and have him tied up
notice the broken glass on the bottom
right hand corner this seems to match up
with Liz breaking out of the ice sample
room we'll also see her red coat helping
tie this man up it looks like novaro and
Liz make it to that Ice Cavern I'm just
dying to know what they find this might
be lizz's son Holden pointing his hand
out just like Navarro's mom Anders Lund
and that female victim with only two
episodes left there's still a lot of
mystery left to uncover and I want to
hear your thoughts and theories in the
comments below according to IMDb there
won't be a new episode Super Bowl Sunday
but I hope you'll join me the week after
for the remaining episodes thanks for
watching be sure to like And subscribe
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember chaoa